hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my first Jessica Jones video so what
I'm gonna do is just a breakdown of her
character and her history in the comics
they just announced that they're taking
the aka out of the title so if you never
called it aka Jessica Jones you were
doing the right thing that was just a
working title it was meant to be a play
on the fictional company that she
started in the comics alias private
investigations the character was created
by Bendis to be like like a stand-in for
Jessica drew he was gonna use Spider
Woman in this alias comic that he was
writing but it didn't work out in the
planning stages so he had to create an
original character he needed someone who
was kind of a washed-up superhero to be
a private investigator investigating
superheroes in the context of the
Netflix series that's essentially what
the characters gonna be doing but she
has this whole big history she's been
part of the Avengers she has super
powers so what we see in the TV show
will be like a small slice of her life
like when she's at her lowest the
essence of her characters that she's
just constantly felt demoralized to her
whole life constantly felt like an
outsider so she just has no sense of
self-worth you can kind of see what the
arc of the series is right now in the
same vein as daredevil did during season
one of his show she's gonna go you know
enough is enough she'll have like a big
call to action we can thank David
Tennant for that he's playing a really
nasty Marvel villain called the purple
man but rewind in time so Jessica Jones
is a character that you know because
Bend is created her relatively recently
you know in the last like 15 years he
had two retcon her into the Marvel
Universe in this really big way so
historically she's crossed paths with
some of the biggest Avengers but we've
only learned about it recently so it's a
bit weird in the comics so whenever she
debuted in her first title in the alias
comics she was already working at as a
private investigator her back stories
told in flashbacks so Ben has made it so
that she originally went to the same
high school as Peter Parker they kind of
knew each other she was really shy she
had a crush on him when she was going up
to finally tell him is when he got bit
by the spider so she's like a gwen stacy
mary jane almost ran in almost romance
of Peter Parker's later her father who
worked for Stark Industries got two free
passes to Disney Land from Tony Stark
himself on the way back from that trip
they got in a car accident with a
military convoy carrying radioactive
chemicals so you see we've got like the
standard Stanley
you active waste origin story you know
with her superpowers but she went into a
coma her father died eventually she was
adopted by the Joneses that's where she
gets the Jones name went back to Midtown
high school and continued to be a normal
teenager that just happened to have
superpowers all the normal high school
stuff happened to her Flash Thompson
picked on her just like he picked on
Peter Parker who at this time had
already become spider-man Peter tried to
get close to her but she pushed him away
remember that's a common theme across
her entire life she just pushes people
away eventually she sees Peter fighting
Sandman at their school and is inspired
to use her powers to help people that's
the beginning of the Jule Jones era she
takes that name and tries to start
fighting crime she has limited and
vulnerability super strength and she can
fly but not very well so she does have
legit powers but she just never got like
really amazing at using them in her
earlier she ends up running into
zebediah killgrave a daredevil villain
that's the purple man he uses his powers
to take mental control of her and make
her commit crimes for him his power is
that he gives off this pheromone that
gives him control of people he
controlled big crowds of people all at
the same time after eight months of
psychological torture in control he
finally sends her on a mission to kill
daredevil she ends up at the Avengers
mansion Scarlet Witch runs into her it
breaks the psychic cold she falls into a
coma
The Avengers tried to help her Captain
America ends up offering her membership
in the Avengers but she pushes him away
too just because she's been so
demoralized member does this been eight
months of constant torture her big
comeback came during the pulse storyline
where she takes the name the nitrous it
started fighting crime again you can
actually be part of that storyline on
Marvel unlimited not not all of Jessica
Jones's storylines are on Marvel
unlimited it's kind of a pain in the
butt so during her time as the nitrous
she went up against the owl leland
owlsley that's this guy from the
daredevil Netflix series we actually saw
him she ends up running into and
befriending both Luke Cage and iron
fists they develop a friendship
obviously she went on to develop a
romantic relationship with Luke Cage
later and they have a baby together the
cool thing about their baby is is that
she's named Danielle she's named after
iron fist Danny Rand and she became
Captain America she's like this
invulnerable super-strong Captain
America because
she got both luke cage's and Jessica
Jones's powers but in present day in the
series she's still a baby so whenever
you see her is Captain America it's
always like some far future storyline so
later in her timeline Jessica Jones
ended up working at the Daily Bugle for
a little while for Jay jonah Jameson
ended up quitting you when he started
going after the New Avengers eventually
joined the New Avengers and became Power
woman it's this really vicious cycle
with her you know whereby she'll be a
superhero something terrible will happen
she'll get demoralized and quit and
eventually some big call to action will
happen and she'll become a superhero
again so her story is all about
recognizing your own self-worth in the
context of the Netflix series even even
if she does become fully actualized by
the end I don't know if she's gonna be
wearing a costume or not she does in the
comics
she's like a number of different
costumes but if you're invulnerable and
super strong there's not much reason to
wear a costume like daredevil wears a
costume like Batman wears a costume to
scare the out of criminals and to
protect them from from bullets and
knives Luke Cage is a good example of
someone who does not need a super suit
super strong super invulnerable like I
said they haven't announced an official
premiere date but what I think they
might do is try and sync it up with
another big Disney or Marvel movie the
problem is is that the only other big
Marvel movie this year is ant-man that's
only a couple of weeks away and it's
possible that they're still trying to
finish Jessica Jones episodes they have
to finish all thirteen before they can
drop them and a lot of you are asking
about the timeline because we're getting
like season two of daredevil before we
get Luke Cage and it's gonna get a
little bit wonky what's probably gonna
happen is is that the show's will move
in real time just like the Marvel movies
Jessica Jones whenever it starts will
pick up like eight months in the
timeline after the end of daredevil but
what's gonna happen is is will get
Jessica Jones at the end of this year
then we'll get daredevil season 2 right
before Captain America Civil War then
we'll probably get Luke Cage because
they're just starting pre-production on
that right now and then we'll probably
get Jessica Jones season 2 what about
iron fist everyone wants to know when
iron fist is coming that's like the last
thing they do before they do the
defenders miniseries I would think we're
gonna see iron fist season 1 sometime at
the beginning or during 2017 who knows
because by that time we'll be on
daredevil season 3
hopefully Netflix will clarify some of
this is just they probably don't have
specific dates in mind for what
they're gonna drop stuff it probably
just depends on when they finish making
it a lot of you also asked you know how
do these Netflix shows that Marvel is
doing make money and the answer is they
don't make money
Netflix gets all of its money from
subscribers just like HBO so the only
real benchmarks that they have to
measure whether or not a show's popular
is by how many people stream it and by
how much their subscriber base grows
whenever they premiered the series all
things considered though all these
Marvel series super popular we will have
multiple seasons all the way up through
Avengers infinity wars so do not worry
so what's gonna happen is as we get
closer to Jessica Jones I'll start doing
more videos for that series you know be
sure to subscribe to get everything if
there's any other you know Netflix
related videos that you guys want me to
do just let me know the schedule is a
little wonky today so tomorrow I'll be
doing a new flash video new Game of
Thrones don't worry there's been a lot
of Batman vs. Superman stuff too so if I
feel like that's exciting enough I'll
make a video for it too while you guys
wait for that stuff to post you can
click here to learn all about the
Punisher joining daredevil season 2 I
know everyone's really excited about
that and you can click here to learn
about mirror master joining the flash
season 2 thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow
you